okay it's time for hatred mail hatred
mail of course when we hear from the
haters of the David Pakman show their
voicemails rather their emails
interpretive Lee read by a professional
voice-over artist the right of the
people to keep and bear hates shall not
be infringed patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom okay this is
just someone who I guess is is so angry
with me that they want me to do
something that would be really bad that
I don't want to do and I'm not going to
do take a listen to this David you are a
sick deranged a snowflake try suicide
America will be better off if you were
dead any what you [ __ ] weakling and
take the tour who birthed your loser ass
to hell when you go Germany has embraced
a these Nazi past and you a just another
Jew hating Nazi it's only a matter of
time before all you deranged illiberal
socialists start exterminating Jews all
over Europe all you suck your Muslim
masters you smell yeah so listen I don't
I don't like to joke about suicide so my
only commentary is if you are in a
situation where you were thinking of
harming yourself or it is something if
you are in a situation where you want to
talk to someone please be aware that the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline is
available 24 hours a day okay
the numbers 800 273 8255 this is serious
business okay and I'm not even going to
indulge the content of this hatred mail
other than to say I want everybody in
the audience to know that they can
always talk to someone the National
Suicide Prevention lifeline is available
eight hundred two seven three eight two
five five . okay that's it that's what I
want everybody to know